Selena Gomez and Justin Bieber spotted
kissing as the source tells ET the
relationship is back on in a big way
things seem to be getting serious again
for the on and off couple what do you
mean
the wolf singer was spotted in Panorama
City California on Wednesday supporting
her bow at his hockey game the two were
photographed packing on the PDA even
sharing a kiss inside the LA Kings
Valley Ice Center and while they have
yet to confirm the status of their
relationship a source tells ET that
selena and Justin are very much together
and our exclusive quote they're really
happy and enjoying this time together
they've both grown a lot over the years
and are excited to have reconnected you
got a fetish from the source adds that
even their friends who were skeptical
about the reunion have gotten on board
Justin definitely had to prove himself
to her friends to regain their trust and
he's doing a good job her friends have
come around and can see that this time
is different
[Music]